this is some of this one of the benefits
of me saying save that money save that
money obviously i invest i talk about
all the time but i'm going to tell you
guys the story right now this is that
crypto story david uh
yeah so we're gonna we're not gonna talk
about that um different types of mutual
funds we're just gonna move right along
okay um this is every week we do the
crypto corner this crypto corner this
story is actually my story okay okay so
let's hear it um
let me explain how i got into crypto and
bitcoin and then i'll give you a you
know my two cents on on what's going on
right now because the crypto market is
insane
okay
so let me take you back the year was
2016.
okay let's pull up this picture tell me
the story
pull up these two pictures
and
my best i have a couple best friends my
best friend is a guy named adrian we'll
leave his last name out of this one
first take the group pick the group so
this guy adrian he's in this picture
um
yeah he's he's this guy right here he's
a cnbc journalist he worked for cnn
total smart dude talented
he was in between uh career paths right
there in between jobs and he says dude
i'm really looking into this bitcoin
blockchain bitty bop crypto stuff and
yeah good luck with all that buddy i
have no clue what you're talking about
2016.
my other buddy chris humphries you might
recognize him from nba fame and and
other things
this picture was in 2016. we were
talking about crypto after the game he
was playing for i want to say the
washington wizards at the time
okay
and it was after the heat game
we're just chatting and we start talking
about crypto
and
i said i have no clue
zero clue about this stuff
2016.
now let's get into the story so this guy
right here says look bro i really
believe in this marketplace you could
take that pick off
um
i really believe in this marketplace
give me 10 grand and let me show you
what i could do i go no dude uh like
what what are you talking about he said
give me 10 grand
i give him 10 grand a week later give me
another 10 grand dude what are you
talking about like this is insane a week
later a week later crypto had gone up
what happened 2016
2016.
long story short i ended up giving the
guy 50 000 oh my god okay 50 grand and
again i i remember mocking
i i would say this thing i don't
know about bitcoin and blockchain and
bitty bops and digital coins and doody
doos and uh and those coins i don't know
any of this stuff right but i trust you
but i trust you i know you know what
you're talking about
i don't know if you're right i don't
know if you're wrong was there ever but
i trust you every time you're like okay
i've given him 40 grand i'll give him 50
grand no but i know but like 30 or 40
grand did you ever say uh oh
yeah i it but here's my point
between savings
and investing
savings is day to day week to week month
to month even year to year right
investments is a five year minimum thing
for me now if you're talking roth iras
and 401ks it's 40 years down the road 50
years sometimes
you know if you're a little bit older
maybe it's 25 years but it's long term
saving short term you know needed now
emergency fund right long term
retirement
plan investing time compound interest
these are two totally separate things
saving and investing so when i knew that
i gave him this 50 gs this was not a
savings thing this is an investing thing
long story short
2017 market crashes it reached all-time
high crashes towards the end of the year
i've given them 50 g's now my 50gs is
like 20 g's
do i sell no
i don't sell the hell do i i don't need
the money again this is an investment
i'm not this is short term
i say all right
he's like you know obviously he feels
bad he's my best friend i don't think
he's gonna run off with the cash best
friend
and um
say all right let's go so what i start
doing is saying all right let me start
learning a little bit about this the
people started talking about it a little
more and then show up the next picture
yeah and then i went to something called
a bitcoin conference down in miami this
would have been 2017
2018 somewhere around that time
young saws younger saws three four years
ago i went you can notice there's a
microphone in my hand
and i started doing interviews about
bitcoin
and i started learning and believe me i
was not a believer at this point
wild crazy people you know
they believe in bitcoin like crazy
amazing content we should probably
repurpose some of that
um
and
it was it was eye-opening how many
people were talking about bitcoin and
why they believed in it so
wholeheartedly wholeheartedly
2017 2018 the market didn't make a
comeback
until
what mid to late 2020 summer of 2020 is
when the market came back and bitcoin
went back 20 000 30 000 what happened
and then it crashed again
but point is bitcoin has been on the map
for sure for a handful of years this was
not at a time when bitcoin was the most
popular thing on the planet these were
things peop 2018 people were still
doubting bitcoin what's my point about
all this
this is how i got into bitcoin
let me explain something
i guarantee you knowing me
i would now
in 2021
just
be looking into bitcoin and crypto
because i'm a traditional guy when it
comes to this yeah stock market save
build wealth long term take on some risk
not crazy risk i'm not gambling money
i'm not day trading i'm not forexing
stick to what you know stick to what you
know it's you know but i'm so thankful
that i believed in him so now
because of him i own a few bitcoin
a couple different alt coins but most
importantly and this is definitely
something that i would totally
not even look at at all these days
because i think it's just a bunch of
nonsense
is he took that money and he
invested in an nft platform one of the
bigger nft platforms out there so let's
just say this
sometimes it's not what you know it's
who you know
and sometimes you just bet on the right
horse or you know if you trust someone
and you can kind of split the risk
because i'm like look i'll provide the
capital you do the work i don't know
about all this kind of stuff like that
the point is i bet on the right person
now my 50 g's
is significantly more than that let's
just put it that way okay
so that's how i got involved in crypto
so now what can you take of this maybe
you're the person
who knows a lot about crypto but you
don't have capital
now you need to start talking to some
friends listen i understand this market
trust me let me let me
let me long term prove to you that we
can do something here trust trust is a
major factor here
or if you're the person
right that doesn't know about
crypto right
um
but you've got some capital maybe you
approach people
that know about and say hey where do i
get started
again be a sponge
learn soak it all in if you give up
about this marketplace
figure out a way to get into it i
believe that you should have
five to ten percent of your portfolio
into something
very risky like crypto if you're young
let me say that again if you're young
now's the time to get involved in
something a lot riskier than what you're
used to okay whether it's a bitcoin
which is less risky in the terms of
whether it's shibu inu whether that's
nft
i'm not saying to go all in on this at
all but if you were to now's the time
but i'm just saying five percent let's
say you've got 10 grand
to invest you've you're out you're
debt-free i still believe in my
foundation you're not paying debt you're
not drowning in debt right i'm not
talking about student loans i'm talking
about credit card debt automobile debt
the consumer debt the bad debt right
um
and you got your cash on hand you're
good you've you've started with your
401k you're like you've done the basics
take 500 bucks a thousand bucks give it
a shot with crypto this is
long term
you're not the goal is not to put a
thousand bucks in and then
you it doubles you make two thousand
bucks you pull it out like now what are
you gonna do with it you spend it this
is long-term wealth so if you believe in
this uh marketplace
i didn't believe in the marketplace i
believe in the person that's my point
anyway crypto is so freaking big right
now we see what's happening you know
people make an absurd amount of money
you'd be foolish to dismiss this i agree
that's my point i know dave ramsey is
one of the ones that's like
well what do you expect he's 60
something years old do you think he's
crypto i think majority of crypto is
millennials in gen zone
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
size cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken